el dinero es el motor de las
negociaciones climáticas y se necesita
mucho para combatir el cambio climático
hasta un billón de dólares las
delegaciones negocian como conseguir
este financiamiento pero el dinero
público suele ser más complicado de
conseguir y por eso hay muchos que
apuestan por incluir al sector privado
uno de ellos ha sido el enviado especial
de la Casa Blanca John Kerry que hoy
anunció un plan que permitiría a las
empresas privadas comprar proyectos de
mitigación en países de desarrollo para
acelerar su paso a energías renovables y
así alejarse de los combustibles fósiles
este sistema de compensación de carbono
tiene algunos detractores que creen que
puede des incentivar a los países
contaminantes a reducir sus emisiones
Alfredo ni Castro vicepresidente de
mercados de carbono the stonex nos habló
de cómo este sistema que propone querry
afectaría o beneficiaría América Latina
hay muchos países en América Latina que
aún tienen su matriz energética muy
basada en combustibles fósiles no y por
eso con ese aporte de capital a través
de los créditos de carbono los WhatsApps
desde Estados Unidos va a permitir los
recursos para acelerar la transición
energética y permitir que que los países
que aún utilizan combustibles para
generación eléctrica pasen a utilizar
otras fuentes renovables de energía y
tras cuatro días de Cumbre hoy fue el
primero en el que se vieron protestas de
activistas climáticos que en pequeños
grupos exigían dinero para pagar por los
daños inevitables o ya causados por el
cambio el cambio climático unas
protestas que a pesar de ser totalmente
pacíficas estaban rodeadas de varios
agentes de la policía de la ONU y de
seguridad privada hay que recordar que
Egipto al contrario de lo que suele
pasar en otras conferencias de las
partes de la Cumbre climática solo
permite manifestaciones o marchas en
lugares dentro del Recinto de la
conferencia